well the big game is approaching and if
you're looking for a fun and tasty
recipe for game night Chef Jeff with
Smith's Food and Drugs the sponsors of
the segment is showing us how to make
chicken enchilada bean dip
hello everybody I'm Chef Jack from
Smith's today's recipe is perfect for
any game day party or any Gathering and
you want to serve a great dip we're
going to be making a chicken enchilada
bean dip super easy to make we're using
rotisserie chicken that you can buy at
the deli your local Smith we got a few
other easy ingredients like Black beans
and some enchilada sauce cream cheese
let's get right to it we're going to
start with basically starting our
vegetables in this we're gonna put some
onion and peppers in this but we don't
want the onions and peppers to you know
be raw when they go in there so we need
to cook them just a little bit
so we're gonna do this in a cast iron
pan because uh this whole thing is going
to go in the oven so either cast iron or
any other oven safe dish is what we want
to do this in got a lot of sizzling
going on here get those going next is
going to be an Anaheim chili now what
that is is a chili that looks like this
otherwise known as maybe a Hatch Chili
it's just a kind of like a large
jalapeno maybe not quite as spicy as a
jalapeno but a lot of really great chili
flavor so in goes that I seeded it and
then diced it
and so then after that I'm going to add
some salt and pepper and then just kind
of let those soften up it usually takes
them about three to four minutes to to
get translucent and soft so we'll let
those do their thing
okay so once your onions are translucent
your chilies are soft basically
everything in the pool now so let's I'll
just go through and tell you we've got
red enchilada sauce
we've got rinsed black beans I have
smoked paprika and garlic powder I've
got cream cheese that's been softened
um this is sour cream
so as this melts together just gets
really bubbly and just fantastic this is
salsa verde
get in there and then I've got some
rotisserie chicken
that I've pulled and then some
mixed the Mexican cheeses there that I
have shredded so basically now I'm gonna
mix this up and then it's gonna be ready
to go in the oven
okay so I've got it all mixed in managed
to not make a huge mess believe it or
not this goes in a 400 degree oven for
approximately 15 to 20 minutes basically
what you're looking for is to be bubbly
on top and all the cheese melted just
look for bubbling 15 to 20 minutes 400.
okay so after about 20 minutes it should
be bubbly and Browning and delicious
let's get it out of the oven carefully
see let's put it in its final resting
place here don't want to burn my
place mat so basically now serve it with
some tortilla chips I'm gonna do an
avocado with it maybe put some olives
lime wedges you know all the regular
things some sour cream all those types
of yummy things to make it perfect so
what I'm going to do is take my avocado
and kind of fan it out
I'm gonna put it right here
and then I'll take some green onion
put on the top of it you can find all
these ingredients at your local Smiths
thank you so much for watching thank you
for shopping we'll see you all next time
bye everyone
thank you to Smith's Food and Drug for
sponsoring this segment for more
information you can visit
smithsfoodanddrug.com we'll be right
back